by June Taylor being the acting
returning officer at the election of a
member of parliament for the Salford and
Ethel's parliamentary constituency held
on the 8th of June 2017 give notice
that's the number of votes recorded for
each candidate is as follows
Christopher Barnes UK Independence Party
2320 Rebecca long Bailey Labour Party
31,000
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wendy Olsen green party 809 John
Campbell read Liberal Democrats 1286
Jason Sugarman the Conservative Party
candidates twelve thousand and thirty
six the number of ballot papers rejected
was as follows one savvy official mark
zero voting for more than one candidate
thirty-two writing or mark by which the
voter could be identified one unmarked
are wholly void from certainty 76 the
total number of ballot papers rejected
was 109 the total number of votes cast
was forty seven thousand seven hundred
and thirty which represents sixty-one
percent of the electorate the majority
of 19136 I hereby declare that Rebecca
long
elected as Member of Parliament for the
sulfur dimethyl parliamentary
constituency
[Applause]
[Music]
Thanks now I'm truly honored and humbled
to get another opportunity to represent
the people of Salford in Eccles as their
voice in Westminster and I want to give
special thanks tonight to the returning
officer the staff at the camp tonight
the staff in the polling stations the
police and the security staff that we've
got at the venue and the candidates who
run a very very hard and a good campaign
throughout the last six weeks
importantly I want to thank John
Ferguson my agent and friend he's been
there a rough and an inspiration to me
not just throughout this campaign but
four years beforehand I'd also like to
thank Stuart Dickman who's out there
tonight
for doing such a fantastic job of
coordinating this campaign along with
Alex Callaghan and Alex Olin as well and
it also like to thank our Labour Party
members many of whom are here tonight
because they worked tirelessly over the
last six weeks with through rain and
shine practically 24 hours a day to get
the result that we've got tonight
they've knocked on pretty much every
door that they can possibly lay their
hands on in the constituency and they've
stuffed envelopes to within an inch of
their life in the campaign office and
they've been an inspiration to me
they've kept me going in the dark times
and they've celebrated with me in the
good times what most of all I want to
thank the people of Salford and Eccles
for having this opportunity once again
because there's no place on earth like
sulphate we've got warm hearts a rich
history and a fire in our bellies for a
better world that no one's ever going to
file and over the last two years I've
really enjoyed representing the people
of Salford and Ethel's
but some of the things that I've seen
quite frankly have been soul destroying
I've seen our public services before
apart industry starved and investment
and support for the most vulnerable
caught I see people in my constituency
office on an almost weekly basis who
aren't able to get home to live in and
some of those who have got home living
in conditions that would rival Rockman
the slum landlord from the 1970s if
anybody can remember
him we've got people who are walking
miles every day on zero hour contracts
getting to the place of work only to be
told there's no work today and the car
you gonna fall the bus fare home and
we've got people in work who are having
to rely on food banks because they don't
earn enough money to make ends meet and
then we've got those struggling to find
work who will be in sanctioned for the
most unjust reasons and having their
benefits cut to the extent that they
can't survive they're pushed over the
edge into destitution but the people of
Salford and Eccles have done everything
over the last two years there's been
asked of them and it wasn't the people
of Salford and apples who crushed the
economy in 2007 2008 it was greed that
crushed our economy
[Applause]
and in all the people of Salford who
allowed multinational corporations and
the financially elite to hide their
money in the Cayman Islands while
starving those businesses here in
Sulphur who were doing the right thing
and it wasn't the people of sulphur to
allow people like Phillip green to
assets trip great British companies
leaving workers jobless and destitute
and you know what it wasn't the people
of sulphur to slash taxes for the most
wealthy whilst cutting support for the
most vulnerable now this is the sixth
richest economy in the world and it's
about time the people of Salford and
Ethel shared in that wealth is about
time they were part of a new economy
where Britain becomes a world leader in
industry and where that industry and the
prosperity it generates reaches out to
every region and every part in this city
and it's about time that Salford was
part of a written for the many not the
few
now at the start that we're a city with
a fire in its belly a city who stands on
the shoulders of giants those who fought
in Betsy Square those brave men and
women who fought for a better world that
came after them then put their
livelihoods at risk their incomes just
to stand up for what they believed in
and the people of Salford who now fight
just to make ends meet now I believe
that the people of Salford and ankles
deserve a written for the many not the
few and I stand on the shoulders of
those giants and I intend to fight for
them until we get a Britain for the many
thank you
[Applause]